[Music]
Hello friends and members of the sum TV
Secrets unsealed family welcome to I'd
like to know our Bible question and
answer program that we have such a good
time
answering your questions each and every
week when we come to you uh we want to
thank you for your questions and we want
to encourage you to send them because
without your questions of course this
program could not exist so we encourage
you to send your questions to us we will
try to get to them now I make you this
pledge and promise because sometimes you
don't hear your question answered the
first week or the second week we promise
that we will get to each and everyone
that is a pledge we make to you in
deference to the time that you take to
send them if you send them we will
answer them from the word of God if
indeed an answer can be found so we've
got a lot of questions and that's a
happy Dilemma to have but it takes us a
little while to get through them so we
promise you we will do precisely that if
you will send them in should you want to
get in on the fun we encourage you to
write us at TV at some tv.org that's TV
at susum as in Mary tv.org
RG we will get to your questions just as
soon as we can as I said I'm CA Murray
and I'm in the company of our president
and founder Pastor Steven bour Pastor
good to have you here as always it's
always good to work with you
CA
um well without further Ado let's just
pray and then we'll just launch right
off because we got a lot to talk about
so let's pray together father God again
we praise you and thank you for the
privilege of studying your word we are
thankful that the word was written and
constructed by the Divine mind so that
it can be studied it can be understood
and it can be applied to our lives and
in doing so we take one more step along
that road that leads to glory and we do
so in knowledge and Faith because you
have put your power and your presence in
your word so as we open your word this
day we ask you to be the center and
circumference of all that we do and say
so that Christ is glorified his people
are edified and we are encouraged to
indeed take one more step along that
road that leads to eternal life and we
thank you dear father in jesus' name
amen
amen our first question comes to us from
Darlene Newman who I'm given to
understand sent in a question some time
ago and did not get the precise answer
she was looking for so she addresses
this specifically to you my dear pastor
and um uh the question is
it deals with the drying up of the river
Euphrates my question is why do we make
the six of the SE the first six of the
seven plagues literal and then only the
drying up of the Euphrates symbolic it
seems to me to be
inconsistent uh you can't just say the
Euphrates is dried up that's a symbol
and by the way she agrees with that
unless the other six are symbolic also
so how do you make that difference six
literal one symbolic uh walk us through
that if you
will okay this is a very difficult
question to answer within the time
constraints that we have here uh and I'd
like to know usually we have questions
that we can answer in two or three
maximum five minutes but this is a very
difficult question to cover but I'm
going to do my best uh the fact is that
both the Bible and the spirit of
Prophecy tell us that the six plague uh
is expressed in symbolic language so
let's read Revelation chap 16 and verse
12 uh and then uh we'll give an
explanation from the next chapter it
says there in verse 12 and the sixth
Angel poured out his bowl upon the Great
River the Euphrates and its water was
dried up that the way might be prepared
for the Kings from the East so I want
you to get the picture here the sixth
Angel pours out his uh vial or his bowl
upon the great river
Euphrates as a result the Euphrates
dries up and that prepares the way for
the kings that come from the East now um
as Seventh Day Adventist we take this uh
plague to be symbolic it's expressed in
symbolic language but it describes a
real historical event MH um the key to
this is found in chapter
17 by the way the river of Euphrates
flowed through ancient Babylon so we
need to know that the Euphrates is
babylon's River uh in the end time we're
not talking about literal Babylon we're
talking about spiritual Global Babylon
so let's read Revelation 17 veres 1 and
two and one of the seven angels
who had the seven bowls came and spoke
with me saying come here I shall show
you the Judgment of the great Harlot who
sits on many
Waters so you have this Harlot by the
way her name is Babylon uh in verse five
she's called Babylon she's sitting on
many Waters now you'll notice that it
says that one of the seven angels that
poured out the bowls is the one that
comes back in chapter 17 so the big
question is which of the seven plague
Angels came back to John to
explain uh the meaning of the Harlot who
is seeing on many Waters whose name is
Babylon well uh there's no doubt which
one it is because the woman's name is
Babylon she's sitting on many Waters and
Babylon sat on the many Waters of the
Euphrates so this means that we have to
go back to plague number six which is
the one that describes the drying up of
the Waters of the
Euphrates so we know that this is a
further explanation of the six plague
the drying up of the river Euphrates now
why do we say that the Euphrates is
symbolic it's very simple because
Revelation chapter 17 which explains the
sixth plague is actually telling us that
the waters are symbolic it says in verse
15 explaining what the waters are
they're not literal Waters it says there
in verse 15 and he said to me the waters
which you saw where the Harlot sits are
multitude are peoples multitudes Nations
and tongues so we know that the heart of
is symbolic by the way she represents
the Roman Catholic papacy we know that
the waters that she sits on are
multitudes nations tongues and peoples
the chapter tells us that she fornicates
with the kings of the earth uh that
doesn't mean that she's committing
literal adulter with the Kings it means
that she is a church that is linking up
with the political powers of the world
it's a union of church and state in
other words in this system so we know
that the Waters of the Euphrates under
the Sixth plague are the the waters upon
which the hearted is sitting in
Revelation 17 which clearly indicates
that we're dealing with symbolic
language in the sixth
plague now the question is why do we
take the first few plagues the first
five plagues to be literal as well as
the seventh plague we take to be literal
and we take the sixth uh Bowl as being
symbolic well we've already proved that
uh the the six bowl is referring to
symbolic
language why are the other bows literal
uh the reason is very simple Revelation
chapter 17 does not pick up on um on the
other uh plagues it doesn't mention the
other plagues uh and so we take the
other plagues to uh be literal now we
receive a lot of help from uh the spirit
of Prophecy as we usually do uh I want
us to reflect upon uh the chapter God's
people delivered which is great
controversy page 635 that's where it
begins and I'm talking about the hard
copy great controversy the the red book
I'm not talking about the paging that
you have online um Ellen White describes
what the drying up of the Euphrates is
the Euphrates are multitudes nations
tongues and peoples that at the end of
time after the close of probation want
to drown God's people in a moment I'm
going to go back to Revelation 12 to
explain what that means the multitudes
under the leadership of the Harlot
United with the kings of the earth they
want to drown God's people now notice
what Ellen White wrote great controversy
635 with shouts of Triumph jeering and
imprecation throngs of evil men that is
the symbolic Euphrates throngs of evil
men are about to rush upon their prey
what does the word Rush bring to mind
Waters rush so she's saying they are
about to rush upon their prey when low a
dense Blackness this is the fifth plague
by the way a BL dense Blackness deeper
than the darkness of the night falls
upon the Earth so in other words the
Euphrates River symbolically speaking
are is at flood stage and everybody the
multitudes are ready to Avalanche
themselves upon God's people people to
execute the death decree uh by the way
the Bible uses this terminology the
waters in Revelation are not simply you
know multitudes Nations tongues and
people they are nations tongues and
peoples that are enemies of God's people
yes notice Isaiah 17: 12 and 13 woe to
the multitude of many people who make a
noise like the Roar of the Seas and to
the rushing of Nations that make a
rushing like the rushing of Mighty
Waters and then it says the Nations will
rush like the rushing of many Waters but
God will rebuke them that's another way
of saying he's going to dry them up the
Lord will rebuke them and they will flee
far away and be chased like the chaff of
the mountains before the wind like a
rolling thing before the wind in other
words the the waters that are rushing to
destroy God's people God is going to
rebuke them in other words they're going
to be dried up now Ellen White continues
after saying that evil men are ready to
execute the death decree and darkness
now comes which is plague number five
now she's going to comment on Plague
number six in great controversy page 635
same page she says the angry
multitudes interesting word the angry
multitudes are suddenly
arrested that's the drying up of the
Euphrates the waters are
arrested their mocking cries die away
the objects of their murderous rage are
forgotten the waters that wanted to
drown God's people are dried up and then
do you notice that in the sixth plague
it says that the waters are dried up to
prepare the way for the kings that come
from the East now who are the kings that
come from the East Revelation 19
explains it it's Christ and his Heavenly
armies that come to deliver God's people
Ellen White right in harmony with
scripture on pages 640 and 641 of great
controversy the same chapter God's
people delivered she writes this soon
there appears in the East a small black
cloud about half the size of a man's
hand Jesus rides forth as a mighty
conqueror faithful and true in
righteousness doth he judge and make war
and the armies which were in heaven
follow him with anthems of celestial
Melody the Holy Angels a vast unnumbered
Throne attend him on his way notice as
he says soon there appears in the
East and Jesus comes as king of kings
and Lord of lords according to
Revelation 19 and the armies of Heaven
come with him those are those are the
the powers from the East now you'll
notice that white says uh here soon
there appears in the East a small Cloud
about half the size of a man's hand yes
so and that's by the way the seventh
plague when Jesus actually comes from
heaven and so uh we clearly see here
that Ellen White is expounded upon the
symbolic language of the six plague and
she is uh she's describing it in matter
of fact language what it represents in
other words it represents a true
historical event yeah in other words
it's expressed in symbolic language but
it takes place in real life now we need
to go back to Revelation CH 12 for a
moment Revelation CH 12 you see this uh
this uh Gathering of the wicked to try
and Destroy God's people under the
leadership of the Harlot happened once
before notice Revelation 12 and: 13-1
15 and when the dragon saw that he was
thrown down to the Earth he persecuted
the woman and gave birth who gave birth
to the male child and the two wings of
the Great Eagle were given to the woman
in order that she might fly into the
Wilderness to her place where she was
nourished for a time times and half a
time from the presence of the serpent
yes so in other words in the past uh it
says here that uh that the woman was
persecuted for time times and the
dividing of time the church now how was
that how did that persecution take place
verse 15 and the serpent who is by the
way the same dragon that we find in
Revelation 17 yes and the serpent poured
water like a river out of his mouth this
is the same Euphrates although it's not
named like a river out of his mouth
after the woman so that he might cause
her to be swept away with the flood now
is that speaking in symbolic language of
course there's no such thing as a dragon
spewing water out of his mouth to drown
a literal woman the woman represents the
church the serpent dragon represents
Satan working through Rome and the
waters represent the river Euphrates
only this is a past stage yes because it
takes place during time times and
dividing of time now does revelation 12
tell us that there's going to be another
period of persecution in the future yes
which is found it in Revelation 17
because it says in verse 17 it says and
the dragon was enraged with the woman
this is by this is by the way after the
Earth swallows up the waters and
persecution ceases we are in that period
now uh the the Earth represents a
territory of the United States the
United States Rose it gave Refuge to the
pilgrims the Waters of persecution were
dried up but the question is are they
going to be dried are they going to flow
again
and is there going to be persecution
again Revelation 12 tells us and the
dragon was enraged with the woman
because she dried up the waters and went
off to make war with the remnant of her
seed who keep the Commandments of God
and hold the testimony of Jesus that is
Amplified in Revelation chapter 17 MH by
the way um if what's the name of the
person again that sent the question
Darlene if Darlene is really interested
in a full exposition of this uh
eventually she'll be able to watch the
24-hour series that we're going to have
an anchor this year in fact if she's
listening to this program why not come
it begins the 17th of this month the
17th of the month of March March so this
is a very synthetic short answer to a
very complex question because you have
to go back to Daniel 2 Daniel 7
Revelation 12 Revelation 13
Revelation 17 but in short the answer is
that the waters that flowed during time
times the dividing of time in the past
which was the river Euphrates they
wanted to drown the woman are going to
flow again according to verse 17 and
that flowing again is expanded in
Revelation chapter 17 well said I hope
that's helpful and the thing that makes
it all possible because you you've got
to put in chapter 17 because one angel
comes back and tells you about one event
One Bowl right so if if the angel signal
out singles out that one bowl so can we
and clearly it's symbolic yes because
the Harlot is symbolic the water she
sits on are symbolic MH the Kings
represent the kings of the whole world
so in other words the symbolic plague is
explained in symbolic language in
chapter 17 well said well done I hope
darling we sincerely hope that this um
clears away a bit of the fog and uh
gives you some homework to do actually
some restudying uh and to include
chapter 17 in the mix so that uh it does
become a little bit brighter and a
little bit clear thank you so much for
the question uh you gave the pastor
little homework he did a fine job thank
you Pastor
boy all right quickly this is coming to
us from oh no
name um no name again we want to
encourage you send your name but also
send where the question is coming from
because it lets us know the footprint of
the program and uh where we are reaching
and and uh who is uh listening to uh
this particular program many thanks for
your ministry it's a huge blessing could
you please kindly clarify this question
for me what is the biblical position on
woman preaching uh during Divine service
could you please kindly let me know as I
do not want to do anything which is not
biblical I remember we getting this from
from Africa uh just a couple years ago
uh is there any examples in the Bible
where women preach during public worship
uh looking forward to your answer many
thanks in advance Pastor bour well we
don't have a lot of references in the
New Testament to public worship because
basically for the for the first uh
decades uh the the Christians actually
worshiped uh in the synagogue with the
Jews we find that in the book of Acts
repeatedly uh so we don't know exactly
what happened when Christian
congregations were established uh what
we can say is that there's no um there's
no um Prohibition in the Bible for women
to
preach uh the what the Bible says is
that for an elder or for a pastor to be
ordained uh to a church office they must
be ordained a woman preaching in a
worship service she's not occupying a
position of an elder a position of a
pastor which is a leadership position in
the church so Ellen White preached many
times many many times and and in the
ministry of Ellen White there were great
women evangelists in the sth Day
Adventist Church who preached a full
Evangelistic series yes and preached in
churches so there's no prohibition that
I can find of women preaching in a
service in a worship service uh the
prohibition is for women to be ordained
to a leadership position like Elder and
Pastor or Bishop in the church and if
you go to Corinthians and that let them
keep silent in the church that is not
that is not what that is well you notice
the context the women were Rabel rousing
in the congregation in the congregation
right so so it's dealing with a
different issue well done I think that
that that ties a nice little bow around
that particular issue uh we've got time
to squeeze in maybe one more if I could
make a suggestion just quickly here we
we don't have a lot of time but I wrote
an article the title of the article is
uh Reflections on San
Antonio uh I wrote it just a couple of
months after the general conference
session where this issue was dealt with
yes and I would recommend uh those who
are watching to request this newsletter
article that I wrote Because it not only
deals with the ordination of women
pastors it deals with the issue of
ordination of women Elders yes which the
Bible does not approve of either mhm all
righty um well let's see if we can
squeeze it in Heather um I was sure that
you would have
commented on a piece that she sent in
about biblical
translations um let's see I know that
when I found these I was astounded at
what it was telling me and thought it
would have the same effect on you um I'm
not sure what she is referring to with
Biblical translations perhaps you do
since the question is addressed to you I
think what she is talking about is that
she's probably read many versions and
she's amazed that the differences
between the different versions but we
need to understand that a Bible version
is just that it's a version other words
it's a translation that is prepared by a
certain individual or by a committee and
uh when they translate they translate
differently uh although when you look
carefully you'll find that even though
words different words are used Etc
uh they basically have the same gist and
so um you know don't get all bent out of
shape because there are different uh
phrase different way of phrasing the
Bible verses uh just try and find the
central idea that uh that the
translators trying to get across and
there are many um you do and I know I
follow the same practice when we're
writing a message something I have
several open in front of me and you try
to cross reference and see which one
most most accurately uh says what you
what you needed to have said and and
because different people Express things
different ways uh uh not necessarily
good or bad just one may be a little
more accurate one may be a little more
on point than the other so you just go
through that's one thing about being a
pastor people give you Bibles as
Christmas gifts birthday gifts wedding
gifts anniversaries everybody you so you
end up with tons of Bibles and of course
if you've got a good uh computer uh you
can get Bible Hub or some other thing
that has many many translations that
will give you a good working start on on
on you you can use uh you know there's a
little literal translation called
Young's literal translation you want
word for word translation that's a good
one there are Dynamic versions yes uh
there are
paraphrases and then there are
interpretations like uh Jack Blanco's
the word yes you know it's basically
some verses are really expanded
tremendously beyond the text yes uh but
just try and find the the trans a
translation uh not a dynamic one but a
real translation yes and uh you'll be
able to get the gist of uh what the
original says I tend to put paraphrases
at the bottom because they tend to be
the most loosely uh if you want
something a little tighter you want to
go with a good translation well again I
hope that you have been blessed our time
has fast slipped into eternity allow me
in closing to wish you all both Grace
and peace through our Lord and Savior
Jesus Christ we'll see you again soon
and God God bless
[Music]